hey everyone what's up this is luca
nigoyda i'm a data scientist and
ecologist and i'm super stoked to be
launching my new course on data
visualization in r for ecologists so
this is the course that i wish i had
as a grad student in ecology if you're
an ecologist or a biologist and want to
quickly learn the essential tools for
making good figures
this course is for you i try to
summarize everything together in
this nice concise three hour short
course that goes over all the basics of
plotting data efficiently and
effectively trying to reduce the r
learning curve as much as possible just
to the essential tools that you need to
really create
professional and publication ready
figures in our
through project based lessons and
exercises i really just take you by the
hand beginning with the most
basics such as how to plot figures using
rs base package
but then moving on to more advanced
topics such as gg plot 2
what it actually is how it works and
beginning to create plots using gg plot
2
specifically focusing on five of the
most essential
and common figures that you find in
ecology and how to plot them how to
customize them how to annotate them
along the way of course we're also going
to cover how to save and export your
figures
and then also some of the best practices
for creating publication quality figures
though this is an introductory course to
data visualization
i do assume that you're going to be
coming into it with just a little bit of
a background in r and r studio
at least the basics knowing how to do
some very basic things with your data
will be important so that i don't
because i'm not going to really spend a
lot of time on
those topics in this course so and it's
just going to go right into data
visualization
if you don't really have that background
if you're still starting from scratch
and don't really know what to do
then definitely check out my other
course on the basics of r for ecologists
which offers a complete foundation in
all the basics that you need to know for
working with data in r
and so if you want to learn more about
that course there's a link down below
or actually maybe it's up above i'm not
really sure where on this website the
links will be
but somewhere on this website where
you're watching this video there will be
links for signing up for
the basics of art for ecologists as well
as this new course on the intro to
data visualization with r for ecologists
thank you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed
please share this with all your friends
with your university with your
department whoever you think might
enjoy these courses or benefit from them
so until then
thanks again and i'll see you there
you